how'd you get roped into all this I
dragged a skyscraper and got a year in
jail for it seems excessive mm-hmm the
tag was 30 stories tall two million hits
on YouTube and I served only half the
sentence let me guess Gibbons to the
rescue
yep he said a lion like me doesn't
belong in any kind of gauge what about
that one on your wrist London 2009
climbed the millennium wheel naked naked
yeah high school oh we all have our
embarrassing enormous kicks the man
get the girl and try to look doped are
you doing it you have two seconds to
comply what
three you wanted me back you could have
just asked me
the device that controls every military
satellite in the world
has fallen into the hands of four very
dangerous guys we need someone who can
move like them quite like them it's time
to be Patriots there are no more
Patriots just rebel and tyrants so which
are you
I'm xxx I'll introduce you to your
ground team all right it comes Red Bulls
poster child I'm not gonna have clowns
watch my back who would you trust a good
the extreme Riley completely insane
what you want I got what you need now
that's the team I can work with here we
go
it's refreshing you actually know what
you're doing down there yeah that's what
she says hey wow these case of yours are
the real kind of trouble you have no
idea what you're up against whatever it
is they're looking for we're gonna come
off short this is me you're not making
me breakfast in the morning we're
willing to die you keep the world safe
how about you I live for this I guess
we're on the same team now you ready to
have some fun I go long
we simplify Slee kick some ass get the
girl and try to look dope why are you
doing
[Music]
dan it feels good to be back
[Music]
you